This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In February 2023, protesters took to the streets of Oxford, England. Many were wearing yellow safety vests and holding flags and signs with complaints about the local government. Specifically, they were protesting new urban planning policies being carried out by their city. That's producer Chris Perube. Now, under normal circumstances, a protest like this might get a little bit of local media attention and then disappear.
这里是《无形之见》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2023年2月，英国牛津的街头涌入了示威者。许多人穿着黄色安全背心，手持标语和旗帜，表达对当地政府的不满。具体来说，他们是在抗议城市正在推行的新城市规划政策。那是制片人克里斯·佩鲁韦。正常情况下，像这样的抗议活动可能只会引起一点当地媒体的关注，随后便会销声匿迹。
But this one was different. Thousands of people showed up. And it was part of a bigger trend. Last year, there were demonstrations happening in countries around the world protesting against an urban planning concept called the 15-minute city. These protesters were angry, saying the 15-minute city represented fascism or socialism or some kind of a human rights violation, which was all really over the top. Because as a planning concept, the 15-minute city is completely inoffensive. In a nutshell, the 15-minute city concept
但这次却有所不同。成千上万的人走了出来。而且这也是一个更大趋势的一部分。去年，世界各国的游行示威都在抗议一个名为“15分钟城市”的城市规划概念。这些示威者情绪激昂，声称“15分钟城市”代表着法西斯主义、社会主义或某种侵犯人权的行为，这实在有点反应过度。因为作为一个规划概念，“15分钟城市”完全是无害的。简而言之，“15分钟城市”这个概念
is the idea that everything that a person needs within a city should be theoretically reachable within 15 minutes of their home by either walking or active travel or public transport. So that's cycling, walking, buses, trains. Burgas O'Sullivan is a reporter for Bloomberg City Lab. It's a very simple concept. It's this idea that basically cities are going to be healthier if you integrate all their uses together. Whenever I've tried to explain the 15-minute city to people, their reaction has usually
是指在理想状态下，人们在城市中所需的一切生活需求，都应该能够在步行、绿色出行或公共交通的15分钟内从家中到达。也就是说，通过骑行、步行、公交车、火车等方式。博格斯·奥沙利文是《彭博城市实验室》的一名记者。这是一个非常简单的概念。它的核心理念基本上是，如果你将城市的各种功能有机结合在一起，城市就会变得更加健康。每当我试图向人们解释“15分钟城市”时，他们的反应通常是
been, oh, I mean, that sounds nice. How could you argue against having a supermarket or a daycare down the street from your house? But in 2023, the 15-minute city entered the world of far-right conspiracy theories, and it became the source of protests, hate speech, and even death threats, all of which shows how even a benign urban planning concept can be demonized by bad faith actors. Okay, so Chris. Yes, Roman? We've been circling this story for a long time, but we're finally getting to it now.
哦，我的意思是，听起来挺不错的。怎么会有人反对家门口就有一家超市或托儿所呢？但在2023年，“15分钟城市”进入了极右翼阴谋论的世界，它成为了抗议、仇恨言论甚至死亡威胁的温和土壤，这一切都表明，即使是一个良性的城市规划概念，也会被别有用心的人妖魔化。好吧，那么克里斯。怎么了，罗曼？我们关注这个故事已经很久了，但我们现在终于要深入探讨它了。
Yeah, this story's been in the news for a couple of years, and people have actually been asking us to do this story, but now there's been a little bit of distance, and it feels like it's the right time for us to talk about the 15-minute city. And so we're gonna get into the internet circus around the 15-minute city, but first, let's talk about where this planning concept originated. So this concept of a 15-minute city, it was, let's talk about where this planning concept originated.
是的，这个故事在新闻里已经传了好几年了，人们实际上也一直在要求我们做这个专题，但现在已经过了一段时间，感觉是时候让我们来聊聊“15分钟城市”了。所以我们将深入探讨围绕“15分钟城市的互联网闹剧”，但首先，让我们聊聊这个规划概念的起源。因此，“15分钟城市”这个概念，它是，让我们聊聊这个规划概念的起源。
So this concept of a 15-minute city, it was first laid out by this guy. Professor Carlos Moreno, Sorbonne University, researcher and creator of the 15-minute city concept. So Professor Moreno, he's this famous urbanist. He's from Colombia, but he's lived in France for a long time. And Roman, you and I talked to him and I found him to be just this really affable guy. Yeah, he's a delight. There's so much energy, I enjoy talking with him too. Totally, he's got this constant broad smile, this trim beard, he just like brings
因此，“15分钟城市”这个概念，最早是由这个人提出的。卡洛斯·莫雷诺教授，索邦大学教授、“15分钟城市”概念的研究员兼创立者。莫雷诺教授是一位著名的城市规划专家。他来自哥伦比亚，但在法国生活了很长时间。罗曼，你和我采访过他，我发现他真的是一个非常温和的人。是的，他非常讨人喜欢。他充满了活力，我也很享受与他的交谈。完全同意，他总是挂着灿烂的笑容，留着修剪整齐的胡须，他就是能带来
a lot of positive energy. I am Buddhist by my culture. This is very important for having inner peace. And at the same time, I am a scientist. So before he coined the term 15-minute city, for years, Professor Moreno, he'd been thinking about urban planning, and he concluded basically the way that we are laying out cities, it just does not work. So let's talk about what's wrong with the way we have laid out cities. Okay, so Ramon, we're going to have to do a little bit of urban planning 101. If you're a regular listener of 99% visible, you probably know these ideas, but we're going
很多积极的能量。按我的文化背景来说，我是一名佛教徒。这对于保持内心平静非常重要。与此同时，我是一名科学家。因此，在创造“15分钟城市”这个词之前，莫雷诺教授多年来一直在思考城市规划，他基本上得出结论：我们规划城市的方式根本行不通。那么，让我们来谈谈我们规划城市的方式究竟有什么问题。好吧，罗曼，我们得做一点城市规划基础知识的普及。如果你是《无形之见》的忠实听众，你可能已经了解这些理念，但我们要
to just recap a few and radically simplify some things. Is that okay? That sounds good. Okay, so for centuries, towns and cities were laid out in this very central way. Like you would have a town square with shops and amenities in the center and then people would kind of encircle that. But in the 20th century,
回顾几个要点，并彻底简化一些事情。这样可以吗？听起来不错。好的，几个世纪以来，城镇和城市的布局都采用这种高度中心化的方式。就像你会在中心拥有一个带有商店和便利设施的城镇广场，然后人们围绕着它居住。但在20世纪，
that changed with the advent of modernism and the rise of certain very influential architects. The actual problem is to find again the condition of nature. And the answer is the major problem of today and tomorrow, the proper occupation of the land. Okay, so that is the voice of Le Corbusier. Corbu! Corbu!
这一切随着现代主义的出现和一些极具影响力的建筑师的崛起而改变了。实际的问题是重新找到自然的条件。而答案就是今天和明天的主要问题，即土地的合理利用。好了，那是勒·柯布西耶的声音。柯布！柯布！
Okay. Yes, so he's a fixture on our show, obviously. You certainly know who he is if you've listened to enough 99PI. And one of his major concepts was this new way of laying out cities that he introduced in the 20s, which he called Radiant Cities. And so his idea was to have cities
好的。是的，他显然是我们节目的常客。如果你听过足够多的《99PI》，你一定知道他是谁。他的主要概念之一就是他在20世纪20年代引入的一种城市布局新方法，他称之为“光辉城市”。所以他的想法是建立这样的城市：
where people lived in tall buildings, which were separated by green space, and people would live away from the noise and the grime of factory life. Exactly, and another one of his big ideas is that a city should be broken up into functional sectors. So this is the concept that people should live in one zone and then work in another zone.
人们住在高层建筑里，建筑之间被绿地隔开，人们可以远离工厂生活的喧嚣和污浊。没错，他的另一个重大理念是，城市应该划分为功能区。这就是人们应该在一个区域生活，而在另一个区域工作的概念。
And all of that culminates with a paper called the Athens Charter, which he published in 1933. Right, so the Athens Charter basically lays out zoning as we understand it today. It said that people should live in one part of the city, work in another, and this was just the way things were done. Yeah, and urban planners take up Corbu's ideas after World War II, and this makes a huge difference in how cities are planned.
所有这一切最终汇聚成了一份名为《雅典宪章》的论文，他在1933年发表了这篇论文。没错，《雅典宪章》基本上奠定了我们今天所理解的分区规划。它指出，人们应该住在城市的一个部分，在另一个部分工作，而这正是当时做事的方式。是的，第二次世界大战后，城市规划师们采纳了柯布的理念，这对城市的规划方式产生了巨大影响。
So suddenly we have zoning, we have residential areas where you can only build housing, and then areas where you can only build factories, and then areas where you can only put up offices and businesses. And that's something that really takes effect post-war along with a second major trend, which is the rise of cars. The automotive city is a very short period in the history of cities.
因此，我们突然有了分区规划，我们有了只能建造住宅的住宅区，只能建造工厂的区域，以及只能设立办公室和企业的区域。这是战后真正开始产生影响的事情，伴随着第二个主要趋势，那就是汽车的兴起。汽车城市在城市发展史上是一个非常短的时期。
This again is professor Carlos Moreno. Massive production of cars has started when Mr. Henry Ford has produced the first Model T. The worldwide presence of a massive car is just after the Second World War. What was the impact just in seven decades of the presence of car. So we've just spent an entire year talking about Robert Moses and how American cities became centered around freeways and driving. I mean, post-war cities around the world
这位依然是卡洛斯·莫雷诺教授。汽车的大规模生产始于亨利·福特先生生产出第一辆T型车之时。汽车在全球范围内的大规模普及则是在第二次世界大战之后。仅仅在七个十年里，汽车的存在带来了怎样的影响。因此，我们刚刚花了一整年时间讨论罗伯特·摩西以及美国城市是如何以高速公路和驾驶为中心的。我的意思是，世界各地的战后城市
became more car-centric and urban planners were building more roads and highways all the time. Exactly, so with zoning, people are getting separated from things like work and school and, you know, movie theaters, leisure, and with zoning, people are getting separated from things like work and school and movie theaters, leisure, and more and more people are taking cars to get to these places. And to be clear, this really is a phenomenon we're seeing in North American cities after World War II.
变得更加以汽车为中心，城市规划师们一直在修建更多的道路和高速公路。没错，通过分区规划，人们与工作、学校以及电影院、休闲等事物隔离开来，而且，通过分区规划，人们与工作、学校、电影院、休闲等事物的距离被拉远了，越来越多的人开始乘车前往这些地方。需要明确的是，这确实是我们在第二次世界大战后的北美城市中看到的一种现象。
This is not necessarily the case everywhere. Right, absolutely. So Professor Moreno, he's looking at these developments and he's thinking, okay, this is not sustainable. So in 2016, he pitches this concept called the 15 minute city as a climate change solution. Basically all the important stuff should be 15 minutes away on foot or by bicycle. Yeah. And I feel like this is really straightforward.
这并不意味着在所有地方都是如此。对，绝对如此。因此，莫雷诺教授在观察了这些发展后心想，好吧，这是不可持续的。所以在2016年，他提出了“15分钟城市”这一概念，作为应对气候变化的解决方案。基本上所有重要的东西都应该在步行或骑自行车15分钟的距离之内。是的。我觉得这真的很直观。
Like this is, this idea predates him certainly. Like many older cities are just naturally like this already because they were laid out before cars and zoning. It's a very simple concept and something that Carlos Moreno would admit too is that it is not a new concept. This is the direction in which planning has been moving pretty much from the late 10th century, starting back in the 60s with people like Jane Jacobs. That's Fergus O'Sullivan again from City Lab, invoking the patron saint of
就像，这个理念当然比他出现得更早。比如许多古老的城市自然而然就是这样的，因为它们在汽车和分区规划出现之前就已经规划好了。这是一个非常简单的概念，卡洛斯·莫雷诺也会承认这一点，即这并不是一个新概念。这是规划发展的一直以来的方向，大致从10世纪后期开始，最早可以追溯到60世纪由简·雅各布斯等人发起。那是来自《城市实验室》的博格斯·奥沙利文，再次请出了步行城市
walkable cities, Jane Jacobs. And by the late 20th century, a lot of these ideas were becoming best practices in urban planning. So Professor Moreno, he takes all these ideas and he basically just gives them a new package, right? And that's why I think the idea of the 15-minute city really resonated with people in this fresh way. What I think Carlos Moreno's idea did that revolutionized this is it allowed people to
的守护圣人简·雅各布斯。到了20世纪后期，许多这些理念已经成为城市规划中的最佳实践。因此，莫雷诺教授吸收了所有这些理念，基本上只是给它们包装了一个新外壳，对吧？这就是为什么我认为“15分钟城市”的理念真正以这种崭新的方式引起了人们的共鸣。我认为卡洛斯·莫雷诺的理念所带来的革命性变化在于，它让人们
sit at the center of that idea. Because when you talk about a 15-minute city, you can sit there and say, okay, what's within 15 minutes of my home? I do have a supermarket, I do have a pub, I don't have a hospital, et cetera. You can work through it and immediately it becomes humanized. You think, what do I need? What do I have and what do I lack? And to be clear, it's pretty unrealistic
处于该理念的核心位置。因为当你谈论“15分钟城市”时，你可以坐在那里说，好吧，我家里15分钟路程内有什么？我确实有一家超市，我确实有一家酒吧，但我没有医院，等等。你可以顺着这个思路思考，它立刻变得人性化了。你会想：我需要什么？我有什么，我缺什么？需要明确的是，
to have everything within a 15 minute walking distance and Professor Moreno totally acknowledges this. But at least ideally, you'd have the most essential stuff close by. This is not a question to build a Louvre museum every 15 minutes. This is not a question to build a cancer hospital every 15 minutes. So, I mean, the concept sounds nice, it sounds simple, but how does it actually work? So there's no one-size-fits-all version of this,
把所有东西都控制在步行15分钟的距离内是不太现实的，莫雷诺教授对此完全承认。但至少在理想情况下，你会把最核心的东西放在附近。这并不是说每隔15分钟就要建造一座卢浮宫博物馆。这也不是说每隔15分钟就要建造一座癌症医院。所以，我的意思是，这个概念听起来很好，听起来很简单，但它到底是如何运作的呢？所以并没有一种放之四海皆准的版本，
but there are some key policy ideas that have become associated with the 15-minute city. does it actually work? So there's no one size fits all version of this, but there are some key policy ideas that have become associated with the 15-minute city. And one of them is reducing strict single-use type zoning, right? So we're no longer going to have residential areas and business areas. Instead, you would make sure that people are living
但有一些关键的政策理念已经与“15分钟城市”联系在一起。它到底是如何运作的呢？所以并没有一种放之四海皆准的版本，但有一些关键的政策理念已经与“15分钟城市”联系在一起。其中之一就是减少严格的单一用途分区规划，对吧？所以我们将不再有纯粹的住宅区和商业区。相反，你要确保人们的生活
a lot closer to where they work. We wanted to mix the users for having in the same area, offices for working, areas for living, green areas, parks, public spaces for people, cultural activities, medical services, leisure activities, in order to offer a diversity of services. So less zoning is one policy. Another might be restricting car traffic in certain areas.
离他们工作的地方更近。我们希望融合各种功能，以便在同一区域内拥有用于工作的办公区、居住区、绿地、公园、供人们使用的公共空间、文化活动、医疗服务、休闲活动，从而提供多样化的服务。因此，减少分区规划是一项政策。另一种可能是限制某些区域的汽车交通。
So you can pedestrianize roads or you can say cars are not allowed in during these hours. You can have congestion pricing. There's lots of versions of that. Rather than saying cars will be banned, cities will be rethought so that cars no longer have such a dominant space. Instead of saying you have six car lanes converging on a roundabout, you just have two and then the rest could be opened up and it could be paved and you could have greenery, you could have sports facilities. So I think it's basically about taking the vibrancy of the town square, that vibrancy that we all recognize if we sort of go to tourist places and having it everywhere, all the way across the urban fabric.
因此，你可以将道路改造成步行街，或者你可以规定在这些时段内不允许汽车进入。你可以实行交通拥堵收费。这有很多不同的版本。城市不会说将禁止汽车，而是会被重新思考，让汽车不再拥有如此主导的空间。你不再看到六条车道汇聚在一个环岛上，而是只有两条，其余的空间可以被开辟出来，铺上沥青，你可以拥有绿化，可以拥有体育设施。所以我认为它基本上就是将城镇广场的活力——那种如果我们去旅游景点时都能认出的活力——带到整个城市肌理的每一个角落。
So there are a few more ideas Carlos Moreno has mentioned in connection with the 15 minute city like more affordable housing, better public transit, connection with the 15-minute city, like more affordable housing, better public transit, but really the 15-minute radius thing and reducing the centrality of cars, you know, that's the crux of the philosophy. And as O'Sullivan pointed out there, there are cities that actually already do this. There are cities that are already kind of close to being the 15-minute city, especially in Europe. And this is just trying to replicate what a lot of older European cities are like. Yeah, but then the 15 minute city also gives them
因此，卡洛斯·莫雷诺还提到了与“15分钟城市”相关的其他一些理念，例如更多负担得起的住房、更好的公共交通，与“15分钟城市”相关，例如更多负担得起的住房、更好的公共交通，但实际上，15分钟半径的概念和降低汽车的中心地位，你知道，这才是该哲学的核心所在。正如奥沙利文所指出的那样，有些城市实际上已经在这样做了。有些城市已经非常接近“15分钟城市”的状态，尤其是在欧洲。这只是在试图复制许多欧洲老城市的样貌。是的，但“15分钟城市”也为他们提供了一种语言来表达他们在做什么，对吧？所以有几个城市立刻跟风。
kind of some language to what it is that they're doing, right? So a couple of cities actually jump on the bandwagon right away. They say, we want to be 15 minute cities, right? One of them is Shanghai. And one of them very famously is Carlos Moreno's hometown, it's Paris. So in 2014, Anne Hidalgo was elected mayor, and a few years after that,
他们说，我们想成为“15分钟城市”，对吧？其中一个城市是上海。另一个非常著名的城市是卡洛斯·莫雷诺的家乡——巴黎。所以在2014年，安妮·伊达尔戈当选市长，在那之后的几年里，
she made the 15-minute city pretty central to their city planning. And she actually named Carlos Moreno as an advisor. So Paris started implementing a bunch of these policy ideas, like partly under the guise of having a more livable city and also around the concept of fighting climate change. They reduced car lanes and they increased the number of cycle lanes into the city center.
她将“15分钟城市”作为城市规划的核心。她实际上任命卡洛斯·莫雷诺为顾问。因此巴黎开始实施一系列这样的政策理念，部分是以打造更宜居城市为幌子，同时也围绕着对抗气候变化的理念。他们减少了车道，增加了通往市中心的自行车道数量。
They pedestrianized certain areas, they made other areas much, much less car accessible and they have tried to increase the green areas by as much as possible, partly because like so many places, Paris is suffering from extreme heat in the summer and they're desperate to try and cool that down. And I gotta say, there is a visible difference in the city, right? Like you see a lot more people on bikes, You see areas where cars cannot go in Paris now. A lot of green spaces where people can walk. So Paris took up the 15-minute city
他们将某些区域设为步行街，让其他区域变得极难驾车进入，并尽可能多地增加绿地，部分原因就像许多地方一样，巴黎在夏天遭受极端高温的困扰，他们迫切希望能给城市降温。我必须说，城市里有着肉眼可见的变化，对吧？比如你在巴黎会看到更多骑自行车的人，看到汽车无法驶入的区域。许多人们可以散步的绿地。所以巴黎将“15分钟城市”
as this kind of organizing principle, but something happened in 2020 that really just thrust it into the spotlight of global urban planning. I think the reason it came into the media and into public discussion with such powerful force was due to the pandemic. It's very much that lockdowns, suddenly everyone is concentrated in their local areas. And because kind of everything had changed, we were rethinking everything about cities.
作为一种组织原则，但在2020年发生了一件事，彻底将其推到了全球城市规划的聚光灯下。我认为它之所以能以如此强大的力量进入媒体和公众讨论，是因为疫情。很大程度上是因为封锁，突然之间每个人都集中在自己所在的社区。而且因为一切都变了，我们正在重新审视关于城市的一切。
Like, why do we live next to each other? What does work for? And one of the things that was super clear as people were walking more and trying to find ways to interact, that it was really nice to be close to amenities. Yeah, and lots of mayors and urban planners, like they start taking this up too. They're hearing this from people. So in the wake of COVID, we're seeing lots of cities passing resolutions and saying, you know, we want to be 15 minuteminute cities. We want to be more like 15-minute cities. So Buenos Aires, Busan, and South Korea. It's not just big cities though. It's not just global capitals.
比如，我们为什么要住在一起？工作的意义是什么？其中一件非常清楚的事情是，当人们走得更多并试图寻找互动的方式时，发现靠近各种便利设施是一件非常美好的事。是的，许多市长和城市规划师也开始采纳这一点。他们从人们那里听到了呼声。所以在疫情过后，我们看到许多城市通过决议并表示，你知道的，我们想成为“15分钟城市”。我们希望更像“15分钟城市”。所以布宜诺斯艾利斯、釜山和韩国。不过这不仅仅是大城市。这不仅仅是全球首都。
There's also some fairly unexpected places that want to become 15-minute cities. Like what? So one American city that developed a plan to become a 15-minute city was Cleveland, Ohio. Okay. I mean, I've-minute city was Cleveland, Ohio. Okay, I mean, I've spent some time in Cleveland, Ohio. It's not especially dense.
还有一些相当出乎意料的地方也想成为“15分钟城市”。比如什么？有一个制定了成为“15分钟城市”计划的美国城市是俄亥俄州克利夫兰。好吧。我的意思是——克利夫兰，俄亥俄州。好吧，我的意思是，我在俄亥俄州克利夫兰待过一段时间。它并不是特别稠密。
It's not that walkable of a city, as I remember. No, totally, but Cleveland's planning commission, they set up a pilot program to change the city's zoning with the goal of becoming a 15-minute city. And another municipality, I was surprised by this, it's a Canadian city I never would have expected to take this up. It always comes back to Canada with you. I am guilty as charged as resident Canadian guy on 99% Invisible.
据我记忆，它并不是一个特别适合步行的城市。不，完全不是，但克利夫兰的规划委员会设立了一个试点项目，旨在改变城市的分区规划，目标是成为一个“15分钟城市”。另一个让我感到惊讶的直辖市是一个加拿大的城市，我绝不会想到它会采纳这个理念。话题总是绕回你和加拿大身上。作为《无形之见》中常驻的加拿大居民，我认罪。
The 15 Minute City has become a very worldwide popular movement. In North America, for example, in Canada, in Edmonton, close to Toronto. Respectfully to Professor Moreno, Edmonton is not close to Toronto at all. That is wrong. Yeah, it's like days and days drive away, right? Yeah, I looked it up.
“15分钟城市”已成为一个风靡全球的运动。例如在北美，在加拿大，在埃德蒙顿，靠近多伦多。恕我直言，莫雷诺教授，埃德蒙顿一点也不靠近多伦多。这说错了。是的，开车得花好几天呢，对吧？是的，我查过了。
It's like a 36 hour drive, if you do it straight. Okay, okay. But I have to be honest, I was surprised to hear Edmonton was planning to become a 15 minute city because it just kind of sounded like a tall order to me. Like it's one of those places where, you know, in theory you can get around without a car. Lots of people do. But it's not super walkable in places. It's a lot more challenging. It's not impossible, but the default is obviously the car at this point. So this is somebody who I would say knows a thing or two about getting around at Edmonton.
如果直行的话，开车大约需要36个小时。好吧，好吧。但我必须诚实地说，听说埃德蒙顿正计划成为一个“15分钟城市”时我感到很惊讶，因为这对我来说听起来有点像个艰巨的任务。就像那些地方一样，你知道的，理论上你可以不用车出行。很多人也确实这么做。但在某些地方并不太适合步行。这要具有挑战性得多。这并非不可能，但很显然，到目前为止，默认选择仍然是汽车。所以这位可以说是对在埃德蒙顿出行略知一二的人。
Hello, my name is Erin Rutherford. I'm a city councilor in Edmonton, Alberta, and I represent a ward in the northwest of the city. So when Erin joined the city council, Edmonton had just approved a new city plan that was based around the 15 minute city because they saw their population growing really fast actually.
大家好，我叫埃琳·拉瑟福德。我是阿尔伯塔省埃德蒙顿市的一名市议员，我代表该市西北部的一个选区。因此，当埃琳加入市议会时，埃德蒙顿刚刚批准了一项以“15分钟城市”为基础的新城市规划，因为他们看到人口增长确实非常快。
They were adding a ton of new cars on the road and it just didn't seem like a good idea to keep going in that direction. So under the new city plan, the city would be more walkable, it would be broken up into districts. They're saying districts across the city of Edmonton. And I'm guessing the residents of each district are going to be 15 minutes away from various
路上新增了大量的汽车，继续朝那个方向发展似乎并不是个好主意。根据新的城市规划，这座城市将变得更适合步行，并将被划分为不同的区域。他们说的是埃德蒙顿全市范围内的各个区域。我猜每个区域的居民距离各种
amenities. Yeah, pretty much. Yeah. So the idea was that each district would have a park and a school and all the things you need within a close proximity. Seeing the trend of more people having to go further and further for work, for the services that they need, because our city's footprint was growing and growing out rather than up. How do we ensure that we're also building a climate resilient city in a city that allows
便利设施都在15分钟之内。是的，差不多。所以这个想法是，每个区域都将有一个公园、一所学校以及你在附近所需的所有东西。看到越来越多的人为了工作、为了所需的各种服务而不得不越走越远的趋势，因为我们的城市版图在不断向外扩张，而不是向上发展。我们如何确保在建设一个气候适应型城市的同时，还能让
people to not have to drive an hour one way in traffic? So by 2022, Paris, Edmonton, according to Moreno, dozens of places around the world have taken up this urban planning concept. But as we know, from here on out, things get very rough. So when we come back, how the far right made the 15-minute city and Carlos Moreno into the Booking Man. So we're back with Chris Perube, and now we have to talk about the messy conspiracy part. Unfortunately, yes. So in 2020, the 15 minute cities becoming popular with urban planners and all these places, but around this time, there was also a major spike
人们不必在交通中单程花上一个小时开车？因此，到2022年，巴黎、埃德蒙顿，根据莫雷诺的说法，全球有几十个地方已经采纳了这一城市规划概念。但正如我们所知，从这里开始，事情变得非常艰难。所以当我们回来时，我们将探讨极右翼是如何将“15分钟城市”和卡洛斯·莫雷诺变成众矢之的的。我们欢迎克里斯·佩鲁韦回归，现在我们必须谈谈那团混乱的阴谋论部分。不幸的是，是的。所以到了2020年，“15分钟城市”在城市规划师和所有这些地方变得流行起来，但大约在这个时候，也出现了
in awful political rhetoric. So Roman, I mean, you remember what it was like in the summer of 2020. It was a brutal time. Yeah, absolutely. And some of the rhetoric, especially like far right rhetoric, it was spilling over into the conversation about urban planning.
可怕的政治言论的大幅激增。所以罗曼，我的意思是，你还记得2020年夏天是什么样的吗。那是一段残酷的时期。是的，绝对如此。而且有些言论，尤其是极右翼言论，开始渗透到关于城市规划的讨论中。
There were a lot of conspiracy theories around lockdowns. There was a lot of people found lockdowns enormously stressful, and then were tending to see the underlying politics of that as inherently sinister. And I think actually that was the springboard. Anti-lockdown activism bled into anti-15-minute cities activism. So that's Fergus O'Sullivan again. He's a reporter at CityLab, who says these online posters were taking this concept and their imaginations were just running wild. So they were starting to make these giant leaps in logic. I suppose the idea of people have heard 15 minutes and then think that cities are going to be portioned into 15-minute zones that are going to be controlled and that you will
当时有很多围绕封锁的阴谋论。很多人发现封锁带来了巨大的压力，然后倾向于将背后的政治视为本质上是邪恶的。我认为这实际上就是跳板。反封锁积极分子融入了反“15分钟城市”积极分子中。那是博格斯·奥沙利文。他是《城市实验室》的一名记者，他表示这些网上的发帖者正在曲解这个概念，他们的想象力简直在野蛮生长。所以他们开始在逻辑上做出巨大的飞跃。我想人们听到15分钟这个词时，会认为城市将被划分成一个个15分钟的区域，这些区域将被控制，而你
therefore need some to pay a fee, pay a toll, have some kind of permit to get in and out of these zones. And of course, there's no part of the 15 minute city that says anything about this whatsoever. I mean, there's congestion pricing, maybe it's kind of mixing with that as an idea, but like there's nothing about the 15 minutes inherently that involves anything remotely like this.
因此需要支付费用、支付通行费，持有某种许可证才能进出这些区域。当然，“15分钟城市”里没有任何一部分提到过这种事情。我的意思是，有拥堵费，也许它作为一种理念与此有些混杂，但15分钟的本质中绝对没有任何涉及这种性质的东西。
So then how does this conspiracy form and then spread? Well, it's not clear who started it exactly, but it bubbled up from kind of the usual far right corners of the internet, some very unpleasant websites that I had to visit to research the story with people saying, you know, this 50 minute city thing, it sounds a lot like lockdowns. And as this is happening, people are making all these leaps in logic, right? That you're going to need a permit to leave your neighborhood and things like that. You know, you can attribute some of this to ignorance, but a lot of this is just bad faith because there's nothing in the policy that says this at all.
那么这个阴谋是如何形成并传播开来的呢？好吧，目前还不清楚到底是谁发起的，但它从互联网上通常的极右翼角落冒泡出来，一些非常令人不快网站——为了研究这个故事我不得不去访问它们——上面有人说，你知道的，这个15分钟城市的玩意儿，听起来很像封锁。随着这一切的发生，人们在逻辑上做出了所有这些飞跃，对吧？比如你需要许可证才能离开你的社区之类的。你知道，你可以把其中一部分归咎于无知，但这其中很大一部分是出于恶意，因为政策中根本没有这样的话。
Totally. But there are these conspiracy theorists who are kind of twisting it and they're actually taking it to an even more extreme level than licenses to leave your neighborhood. It is a kind of potentially a form of tyrannical authoritarian control. Even some people assess some sort of harbinger of a world government. Yeah, it always comes down to that, people getting paranoid about a world government. So this conspiracy theory is picking up momentum. Eventually it all gets kind of lumped in with this idea called the Great Reset. So Roman, do you know about the Great Reset theory?
完全同意。但有些阴谋论者正在扭曲它，他们实际上把它推向了比离开社区许可证更极端的水平。这可能是一种暴政式的独裁控制。甚至有人将其评估为世界政府某种先兆的预示。是的，事情总是归结于这一点，人们开始对世界政府产生偏执。所以这个阴谋论正在获得势头。最终，这一切都被归入了一个名为“大重置”的概念中。所以罗曼，你知道“大重置”理论吗？
Right. I know about this. Yeah. So in 2020, the World Economic Forum during the pandemic, they proposed this project they called the Great Reset. They're having these conversations everybody's having like, oh, should we question some assumptions? What if we did things differently? You know, what if we had a more sustainable world, things like this? But they package it as the Great Reset and they make these videos promoting it, one of which is narrated by King Charles.
是的。我知道这个。2020年，世界经济论坛在疫情期间提出了一个名为“大重置”的项目。他们正在进行每个人都在进行的那些对话，比如，哦，我们应该质疑一些假设吗？如果我们用不同的方式做事会怎样？你知道，如果我们拥有一个更可持续的世界，诸如此类的事情。但他们将其包装为“大重置”，并制作了宣传视频，其中一个视频由查尔斯国王担任旁白。
We have an incredible opportunity to create entirely new sustainable industries, investing in nature as the true engine of our economy. I mean, they immediately run into this branding problem investing in nature as the true engine of our economy. I mean, they immediately run into this branding problem because The Great Reset is a really ominous sounding title. Yeah, especially when it's coming from the World Economic Forum and the British Royal Family. Like, yeah, that sounds not great.
我们拥有绝佳的机会来创造全新的可持续产业，将自然投资为我们经济真正的引擎。我的意思是，他们立刻遇到了这个品牌危机将自然投资为我们经济真正的引擎。我的意思是，他们立刻遇到了这个品牌危机，因为“大重置”是一个听起来很不祥的名字。是的，尤其是当它来自世界经济论坛和英国王室时。就像，是的，这听起来不太妙。
And if you're inclined to think there is a plot to start a one world government, this might contribute to that. And some of these right wing people on the internet are suggesting global elites are using COVID as a way to initiate the great reset, right? This is where their thinking is going. And then those ideas start to go mainstream. It jumps from these far right social media echo chambers to the general population. And that's because of a pretty notorious
如果你倾向于认为存在一个建立一个单一世界政府的阴谋，这可能会助长这种想法。互联网上的一些右翼人士暗示，全球精英正在利用新冠疫情作为启动“大重置”的一种方式，对吧？这就是他们的思维走向。然后这些想法开始走向主流。它从这些极右翼的社交媒体回音室跳跃到了普通大众中。而这要归咎于一个臭名昭著的
right-wing internet guy named Jordan Peterson. So Roman, how much do you know about Jordan Peterson? You know, I don't honestly know a whole lot. I try to avoid him as much as possible because everything I've sort of encountered has been pretty loathsome. Yeah, no, this is a good plan for your mental health. So Jordan Peterson was a professor of psychology at my alma mater, actually the University of Toronto, where I went to university.
右翼网络红人，名叫乔丹·彼得森。罗曼，你对乔丹·彼得森了解多少？说实话，我知道得不多。我尽量避开他，因为我接触到的所有关于他的东西都挺令人作呕的。是的，不，这对你的心理健康是个好计划。所以乔丹·彼得森曾是我母校的心理学教授，实际上就是我上大学的多伦多大学。
The fightin' Leafs. The varsity blues, but thank you. So he doesn't teach there anymore actually. So over the last decade, Peterson has become pretty notorious. He has these ideas about masculinity, you know, and refusing to use transgender people's pronouns. Very famously, he advocated for the all meat diet. So, you know, believe it or not, I'm not a huge fan of the thoughts and works of Jordan Peterson. Yeah, it doesn't sound like you have a lot in common besides your alma mater. No, no. But New Year's Eve 2022, Jordan Peterson tweets some charts about the 15 minute city and the great reset. So he's amplifying this, right? And he adds a quote saying, they're great.
“战斗的枫叶队”。是大学冰球队，但谢谢你。所以他实际上不在那里教书了。在过去的十年里，彼得森变得相当臭名昭著。他有一些关于男子气概的观点，你知道的，拒绝使用跨性别者的代词。非常著名的是，他倡导全肉饮食。所以，信不信由你，我不是乔丹·彼得森的思想和著作的超级粉丝。是的，听起来你们除了母校之外没有什么共同点。没有，没有。但在2022年的除夕夜，乔丹·彼得森在推特上发布了一些关于“15分钟城市”和“大重置”的图表。所以他在放大这种观点，对吧？他加了一句引文说：它们棒极了。
I'm not going to do his voice. I'm sorry. I wouldn't know if you did. It's a very muppety sounding, just trust me, it's very muppety sounding, more so than mine somehow. Okay. The idea that neighborhoods should be walkable is lovely. The idea that idiot idiot tyrannical bureaucrats can decide by fiat where you're allowed to drive is perhaps the worst imaginable perversion of this idea. So this keeps going, it keeps spreading all over the place. And within a couple months, by February 2023, there is the protest taking place in downtown Oxford in England. Thousands of people show up, they are carrying signs that say things like,
我不会模仿他的声音。我很抱歉。如果你模仿了我也听不出来。那是一种听起来非常像布偶的声音，相信我，听起来非常像布偶，不知怎么的，比我的声音还要像。好吧。街区应该适合步行这个想法是很可爱的。而白痴暴政官僚可以通过独断专行来决定你被允许在哪里开车，这也许是这个想法最不可想象的扭曲。所以这一切还在继续，它在各处疯狂传播。在几个月内，到2023年2月，英国牛津市中心发生了抗议活动。成千上万的人出现，他们举着标语，上面写着诸如：
no to 15 minute cities, and then save our freedom of movement, worship and family life. So they're really lumping in a lot of grievances in one message there. Yeah, it becomes this weird magnet for a lot of things. And to be clear about this, like Oxford was proposing
拒绝15分钟城市，以及拯救我们的出行、礼拜和家庭生活自由。所以他们确实把很多怨气塞进了一个信息里。是的，它成了吸引许多事情的奇怪磁铁。需要明确的是，牛津当时正在提议
some pretty strict traffic measures. Like they were really going to limit when cars could come into the downtown. You could still go to the downtown, but you just had to like walk or take public transit. And this wasn't even part of their 15 minute city plan, weirdly, but the protesters, they lumped in this traffic plan and the 15 minute city and all of these other anxieties. And at this point, the Oxford protest, this is actually the first time Carlos Moreno is becoming aware of the internet reaction because they're actually using his name.
一些相当严格的交通措施。比如他们真的要限制汽车进入市中心的时间。你仍然可以去市中心，但你必须步行或乘坐公共交通。奇怪的是，这甚至都不是他们“15分钟城市”计划的一部分，但抗议者将这个交通计划、“15分钟城市”以及所有其他焦虑情绪混为一谈。而在这一点上，牛津的抗议活动，这实际上是卡洛斯·莫雷诺第一次意识到网上的反应，因为他们实际上在用他的名字。
Like they are actually protesting him in Oxford. I was in Paris. I received the photo of the demonstration for saying Moreno is Pol Pot, Moreno is Hitler, et cetera, et cetera. It was very, very difficult. for saying Moreno is Pol Pot, Moreno is Hitler, etc. etc. It was very, very difficult. I mean, this is just so baffling and so tragic. Like even though a lot of the protesters
就像他们在牛津抗议他一样。当时我在巴黎。我收到了游行照片，上面说莫雷诺是波尔布特，莫雷诺是希特勒，诸如此类。这真的非常非常困难。说莫雷诺是波尔布特，莫雷诺是希特勒，等等等等。这真的非常非常困难。我的意思是，这实在是太荒谬、太悲惨了。尽管许多抗议者
are completely mischaracterizing his ideas, it still has an effect on it. Well, I mean, at first he's confused, right? Like this whole idea sounds ridiculous. Like he's an urban policy professor. And now there's these protesters out there saying he's like at the center of world events. This is the psychological bad moment for a scientist.
完全歪曲了他的观点，但它仍然对他产生了影响。好吧，我的意思是，起初他很困惑，对吧？整个想法听起来很荒谬。他是一位城市政策教授。现在却有这些抗议者在外面说他是世界事件的核心。这对一个科学家来说是糟糕的心理时刻。
Because I am a scientist, I'm not politician. I'm not candidate, just a scientist. And from there, this idea starts showing up all over the place on the right-wing internet. Protests are popping up around the world against something called 15-minute cities. Now we've covered the 15-minute cities here on the show and we warned you about them. They'll essentially be contained unless you get permission to leave. That's true. How are they going to put us in there?
因为我是科学家，我不是政治家。我不是候选人，我只是个科学家。从那时起，这个想法开始在右翼网络上到处出现。世界各地开始爆发针对某种叫做“15分钟城市”的抗议活动。现在我们已经在节目中讨论过“15分钟城市”，我们警告过你们。它们基本上是封闭的，除非你获得许可才能离开。确实如此。他们打算怎么把我们关在里面？
The idea that they're starting to roll out in Europe. unless you get permission to leave. That's true. Which is, yeah, that's the idea they're starting to roll out in Europe. Who seems to me that they're using the climate change narrative to, will have travel restricted. I mean, one of the ironic things about this to me, in this like whole Mishgos, is that the 15 minute city doesn't strike me
这个想法是他们开始在欧洲推出的。除非你获得许可才能离开。确实如此。这正是，是的，这就是他们开始在欧洲推出的想法。在我看来，他们似乎在利用气候变化叙事来限制出行。我的意思是，在我看来，这场闹剧中最讽刺的事情之一是，“15分钟城市”根本不给我
as a left wing idea at all. Like if anything, it really hearkens back to an old way of thinking about city planning that about, you know, kind of small towns. Like it's kind of weirdly conservative. Yeah, I think you're right. And I think a lot of city planning people agree with you about that.
一种左翼理念的感觉。如果说有什么不同的话，它真的很让人回想起关于城市规划的旧思维方式，关于那种小城镇。它奇怪地带有保守色彩。是的，我想你是对的。我想很多城市规划界的人也同意你这个看法。
There's nothing inherently leftist about it. I suppose there may be a focus on affordable housing might be seen as that. But really, it's ultimately a traditionalist way of thinking. And people with perhaps a more small-c conservative approach to the world are embracing it more, which makes it slightly paradoxical that people like Jordan Peterson, who are all about going back to some idea, their idea of what was 100 years ago or so against it. So after the protests in Oxford, all this stuff on the internet, things actually escalate even more, right?
它本身并没有什么左翼色彩。我猜对负担得起住房的关注可能会被视为那种色彩。但实际上，它归根结底是一种传统的思考方式。而那些对世界持更为温和保守态度的人正在更多地拥抱它，这使得像乔丹·彼得森这样热衷于回到某种想法（他们对一百年前左右的看法）的人反对它，变得有点自相矛盾。所以在牛津的抗议活动之后，互联网上的所有这些东西，事情实际上进一步升级了，对吧？
So city councillors in Oxford start getting death threats, and Professor Moreno starts to get death threats. This was a very complicated period for me, for my wife, for my family, because I received a lot of threats, death threats. I was under police protection. This was a very, very complicated situation. I cannot stress how weird it is that this delightful, delightful, thoughtful man talking about making cities better for people is getting death threats. It's it's unbelievable. And like, it's obvious, like at this point,
因此，牛津的市议员开始收到死亡威胁，莫雷诺教授也开始收到死亡威胁。对我和我的妻子、我的家人来说，这是一个非常复杂的时期，因为我收到了很多威胁、死亡威胁。我在警察的保护下。这是一个非常非常复杂的局面。我无法强调这是多么诡异，这位可爱、体贴、探讨如何让城市对人们更好的男士竟然收到了死亡威胁。这简直令人难以置信。而且，很明显，此时此刻，
the entire situation is just clearly out of control. So it just kind of snowballs in this kind of hysterical climate, a hysterical climate that of course is exacerbated by having figures like Mark Harper, a government representative, actually feeding it. Okay, so please tell me who Mark Harper is. Well, Mark Harper was actually the Minister of Transportation for the United Kingdom in 2023. So he's one of those people who was appointed during the of Transportation for the United Kingdom in 2023. So he's one of those people who was appointed during the last days of the British Conservative
整个局面显然已经失控了。所以在这种歇斯底里的气候下，它就像滚雪球一样越滚越大，这种歇斯底里的气候当然也因拥有像政府代表马克·哈珀这样的人物实际推波助澜而更加恶化。好吧，请告诉我马克·哈珀是谁。好吧，马克·哈珀实际上是2023年英国的交通大臣。所以他是那些在英国保守党政府最后日子里被任命的人之一。
government. You know, there was lots of chaos. There were a lot of people moving in and out of cabinet. There was the head of lettuce, obviously, that out survived a prime minister. So October 2023, Mark Harper is the transportation minister, not for long, as it turns out. And he starts talking about the 15-minute city, and he starts talking a lot like these protesters. What is different, what is sinister, and what we shouldn't tolerate, is the idea that local councils can decide how often you go to the shops, and that they ration who uses the roads
你知道，当时有很多混乱。有很多人进出内阁。显而易见，还有一颗比首相活得还久的大白菜。所以到2023年10月，马克·哈珀担任交通大臣，不过事实证明没当多久。他开始谈论“15分钟城市”，他的言论听起来很像这些抗议者。不同寻常的、险恶的、我们不应该容忍的是那种当地议会可以决定你去商店的频率，并用配给制限制谁以及何时可以使用道路，并且用闭路电视进行监控的想法。这太荒谬了。这些不是严肃的思想家。这些不是严肃的人。不，不，他们不是。当各大城市试图实施政策以变得更像“15分钟城市”时，这一切都在走向高潮，对吧？
and when, and they police it all with CCTV. This is so ridiculous. These are not serious thinkers. These are not serious men. No, no, they're not. And it's all coming to a head as cities are trying to implement policies to become more like a 15 minute city, right? And they're facing these protests and this pushback, even somewhere like Edmonton is facing this stuff.
他们正在面对这些抗议和阻力，甚至像埃德蒙顿这样的小地方也面临着这些东西。今年早些时候的2024年，埃德蒙顿市议会准备最终敲定城市规划，其中包括这一区域的概念，以及正如我们之前讨论的那样，通往你所需所有便利设施的15分钟半径。而在春天，他们正在就此举行听证会。有些人把一些合理的关切带到了桌面上，对吧，关于密度，关于计划的一些具体细节。
Earlier this year in 2024, Edmonton City Council were going to finalize the city plan, which includes this concept of districts, and 15-minute radius to all of the amenities that you need, like we talked about earlier. And in the spring, they are having public hearings about it. And there were people who brought some reasonable concerns to the table, right, about density, about some specifics of the plan.
但也有很多人在重复这些显然是从互联网上获取的谈话要点。我的理解是，这意味着我需要留在我的社区内以满足我的所有需求，这样城市才能实现其气候计划的目标。我不认为埃德蒙顿人能够如此迅速地承受这种规模的改造实验。政府里没有人想丢掉工作，人们也不想大声说出来。这就是为什么街头公民开始崛起的原因。
But there were also lots of people who are repeating these talking points that they clearly got from the internet. My understanding is that this means I will need to stay within my district to meet all my needs so that the city can meet its climate plan objectives. I don't think Edmontonians can afford to be part of a renovation experiment of this size so quickly. No one in the government wants to lose their job and people don't want to speak up. And that's why the citizens in the streets are starting to rise.
但也有很多人在重复这些显然是从网上听来的论点。我的理解是，这意味着我需要留在我的社区内满足所有的需求，以便城市能够达到其气候计划的目标。我认为埃德蒙顿人无法承受这么快就参与如此规模的改造试验。政府里没有人想丢掉工作，人们也不愿意直言不讳。这就是为什么街头市民开始觉醒并奋起反抗。
And we need you to hear us. And you're not hearing us. So these protesters are coming. This is completely new for like an Edmonton city planning meeting. Aaron Rutherford admits that there might have been something of a branding problem in terms of their proposal that maybe set some people off. It's unfortunate that, you know, they're named districts because a lot of people think that that is very, like,
我们需要你们倾听我们的声音。但你们没有听。所以这些抗议者要来了。对于埃德蒙顿城市规划会议来说，这完全是新情况。埃伦·拉瑟福德承认，就他们的提案而言，可能存在某种品牌重塑方面的问题，这可能引发了一些人的反感。不幸的是，你知道的，它们被称为“片区”，因为很多人认为这非常，
Hunger Games-esque in the visualization that it creates for them, but it's just a planning term that's been used since planning has been a profession. I hadn't thought about that, but that's just a... That is actually, you know, I can sort of see how it conjures that image, yeah. Well, I mean, but still, it's just like, it's the word district.
就像《饥饿游戏》风格，在他们脑海中构建出的可视化画面，但这只是自规划成为一门职业以来就一直使用的规划术语。我之前没想过这一点，但这只是……这实际上，你知道的，我有点能理解它是如何让人联想到那种形象的，是的。好吧，我的意思是，但尽管如此，这就像，这只是“片区”这个词。
It's like you live in a school district too, you know? You do. It's so funny to me that Hunger Games has a bigger footprint than all of social studies education. Yeah, apparently. So, Counselor Rutherford says that this kind of anger, it's pretty new, but it's actually not surprising to her because it's a tone that she is hearing pretty much in every part of her job.
就像你也住在学区一样，你知道吗？确实如此。我觉得太有趣了，《饥饿游戏》的影响力居然比所有社会科学教育还要大。是的，显然如此。因此，拉瑟福德议员表示，这种愤怒相当新颖，但对她来说其实并不意外，因为这种基调她在工作的各个方面几乎都能听到。
The reality is it's not just 15 minute communities, it's police funding, it's, you know, so many topics that we're talking about right now that are creating those visceral responses from folks. So municipalities like Edmonton that are pursuing the 15-minute city, they're faced with this choice, right? Like, do we backtrack or do we forge ahead with this policy that is getting this kind of visceral angry reaction? I mean, if I was facing that kind of pushback, I can imagine backing off. It seems like a completely rational and reasonable thing to do. Totally.
现实情况是，不仅仅是15分钟社区，还有警察经费，你知道的，我们现在讨论的许多话题都在引发人们这种直观的反应。因此，像埃德蒙顿这样追求15分钟城市的城市，面临着这样的选择，对吧？比如，我们是退缩，还是继续推进这种引发此类直观愤怒反应的政策？我的意思是，如果我面临那种阻力，我可以想象退缩。这似乎是一个完全合理且合乎逻辑的做法。完全同意。
And actually what one city did is they just went ahead with the plans, but they just dropped the name 15 minute cities. So it's just like the 16 minute city. Yeah. I think it's a little bit more subtle than that. Just a tiny bit more subtle, but this is actually what happened in Oxford, England. So that's the place where they had the massive protest with thousands of people in the streets. They just dropped the name 15-Minute Cities.
事实上，有一个城市所做的就是直接推进计划，但干脆丢掉了“15分钟城市”这个名字。所以它就像是个“16分钟城市”。是的。我觉得这比那要微妙一点。只微妙了一点点，但这确实是英国牛津发生的事情。那里的街头曾爆发了成千上万人的大规模抗议。他们只是放弃了“15分钟城市”这个名称。
You can get rid of the 15-Minute City concept and keep the policies, because all it is is literally thinking about what's in your area within a 15-minute radius of your home. Get rid of that concept. You can still work towards low-traffic neighborhoods, greater pedestrianization, tree planting, all of these things that individually aren't automatically going to face the same kind of resistance. I mean, we've seen this before, like when something comes up like the Green New Deal and it becomes kind of unpopular and lots of negative associations sort of get attached to it. The people who are really diehards that are for the fundamental concepts they're in,
你可以抛弃15分钟城市的概念，但保留这些政策，因为这实际上只是考虑在你家方圆15分钟半径内你的区域里有什么。抛弃那个概念。你仍然可以朝着低交通流量社区、更多的步行区、植树等方向努力，所有这些单独来看并不会自动面临同等阻力的措施。我的意思是，我们以前见过这种情况，比如当“绿色新政”这样的概念出现时，它变得有点不受欢迎，许多负面联想随之附着在它上面。那些真正坚定的核心概念支持者会说，
just stop calling it the Green New Deal. It's the same thing and it's just part of the Inflation Reduction Act. Right. This kind of thing happens all the time. Yeah. It's smart to me. I don't know. It just seems like smart politics.
别再叫它“绿色新政”了。这就是同一个东西，它只是《通货膨胀削减法案》的一部分。没错。这种事情一直在发生。是的。在我看来这很聪明。我不知道。这看起来就像是聪明的政治手段。
Well, I guess so. But there's other cities who went ahead with these plans and they kept the name 15-Minute Cities. And that's actually what Edmonton ended up doing in the end. So why is that? I mean, it seems like it could be a lot easier to just give it a rebrand. Erin Rutherford explained this to me. So she said in her view, it would actually so distrust if they stopped
好吧，我想是的。但还有其他城市继续推进这些计划，并且保留了“15分钟城市”这个名称。这其实也就是埃德蒙顿最终做的事情。那么为什么会这样呢？我的意思是，重新起个名字似乎要容易得多。埃伦·拉瑟福德向我解释了这一点。所以她说，在她看来，如果他们停止
referencing the 15 Minute City and just went ahead with the same plans anyway. I think we're almost doing a disservice, stopping calling it 15-minute cities because the more we do call it 15-minute cities and the more nothing substantially changes in people's lives, the more that that becomes, oh, my fears didn't come to reality. However, if we stop using that language, that actually creates validation in terms of you might be calling it something different, but now you're just trying to do the same thing under a different name and it can actually fuel this trust further. I can see why she wants to take her time on this.
提及15分钟城市却依然按原计划推进，这实际上会加剧不信任。我认为，如果我们不再称之为15分钟城市，这几乎是在帮倒忙，因为我们越是称之为15分钟城市，而人们的生活却没有任何实质性改变，这就越会变成：哦，我的担忧并没有变成现实。然而，如果我们停止使用这种语言，这实际上会产生一种印证，即你可能给它换了个名字，但现在你只是想换个马甲做同样的事情，这实际上会进一步助长这种不信任。我能理解她为什么想在这件事上花时间。
But what ended up happening in Edmonton then? Well, in June, the city put their plan to a vote and they kept the language intact, you know, despite all of this protest, despite this pushback, but they did add an amendment to placate some people. So the amendment says, the district plan shall not restrict freedom of movement, association, and commerce in accordance with the Canadian Charter of Rights and Freedoms. Yeah, and to be clear,
但埃德蒙顿最后发生了什么呢？嗯，在六月，市议会将他们的计划付诸表决，并保留了原有的说法，你知道的，尽管有所有这些抗议，尽管有这些阻力，但他们确实增加了一项修正案来安抚一些人。因此修正案规定：根据《加拿大权利与自由宪章》，片区规划不得限制行动、结社和商业自由。是的，需要明确的是，
this doesn't change anything at all. No. This is just an additional thing to make people feel better. Like this little bit of an act of political theater just playing along with the game that they've set up. Right, because freedom of movement is actually guaranteed under Canadian law, right? So it wasn't necessary at all. And actually, at the beginning, this bothered Erin Rutherford, because she was voting on this, right? She was a city councilor, and she was worried about giving credence
这根本没有改变任何东西。没有。这只是为了让人感觉好一点的附加举措。就像是一场微小的政治作秀，顺应他们已经设定好的游戏规则。没错，因为行动自由实际上受加拿大法律保障，对吧？所以这根本没必要。而且一开始，这让埃伦·拉瑟福德感到困扰，因为她当时正在对此投票，对吧？她是一名市议员，她担心这会赋予可信度
to disinformation around the 15-minute city. My logical brain and my policy best practices brain wanted to say no, but my human side and my heart and realizing that the harm was greater in not giving people that certainty than the harm of making a redundant sentence in a document swayed me. So the city council adopted the city plan, they added this amendment, and now they're on this path to bringing in some of these actual policy changes to becoming a 15-minute
关于15分钟城市的虚假信息。我理性的部分和政策最佳实践的部分想要说不，但感性的部分、内心以及意识到不给人们那种确定性所带来的危害，要大于在文件中加入一句冗余句子的危害，最终说服了我。于是市议会采纳了城市规划，加入了这项修正案，现在他们正走上将其中一些实际政策变现、打造15分钟城市的道路上。
city. And there's other cities that are forging ahead with it too, despite everything that happened. And then of course, there's Carlos Moreno, the delightful Carlos Moreno, the father of the 15-minute city. Right. So for a while he kept getting these death threats, but eventually, you know, those started to calm down and people
而且尽管发生了这一切，还有其他城市也在坚定不移地推进。当然，还有卡洛斯·莫雷诺，可爱的卡洛斯·莫雷诺，15分钟城市之父。没错。因此有一段时间他不断收到死亡威胁，但最终，你知道的，那些威胁开始平息，人们
actually started standing up for him in public. You know, there was this article in the New York Times that was defending him and he started seeing petitions online. The scientists launched an online manifesto for supporting me. In a few days, more than I think 5,000 or 6,000 have signed it. Professor Moreno noticed people on the internet were actually starting to move on and eventually the vitriol and the threats, those stopped. And he even published a book called The 15 Minute City, where he kind of doubles
实际上开始在公开场合支持他。你知道，当时《纽约时报》有一篇文章在为他辩护，他开始在网上看到请愿书。科学家们发起了一份支持我的在线宣言。几天之内，我想有五六千多人签署了。莫雷诺教授注意到网民们实际上开始向前看了，最终那些恶毒的言论和威胁停止了。他甚至出版了一本名为《15分钟城市》的书，在书中他对
down on these concepts on this whole idea. And I really love that because I'm glad he's getting this idea out there and he's promoting it again. But I have to say this whole thing with the 15 minute city, it just has me really exhausted. Because in the next couple of years, I feel like any hope for positive change is going to be at the local level, right? Like it's going to be concentrated at the municipal level. And if something like the 15 minute city has to go through this gauntlet, you know, marches
这些概念、整个理念进行了加码。我真的很喜欢这一点，因为我很高兴他能把这个想法带出去并再次推广它。但我不得不说，关于15分钟城市的这一切，真的让我精疲力竭。因为在接下来的几年里，我觉得任何实现积极改变的希望都将出现在地方层面上，对吧？也就是说，它将集中在市镇级别。如果像15分钟城市这样的事情必须经历这种磨难，你知道的，游行
and disinformation and death threats, if this is the price of putting forward something like the 15-minute city, how many people realistically are going to stand up and try to make a positive change? Like how many people are going to be like Carlos Moreno? Thank you so much, Chris. Thanks, Roman. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Berube with editing help from Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and George Langford, fact-checking by Graham
还有虚假信息和死亡威胁，如果这就是提出像15分钟城市这样理念的代价，现实中有多少人会站出来尝试做出积极的改变？比如会有多少人像卡洛斯·莫雷诺那样？非常感谢你，克里斯。谢谢你，罗曼。本周的《99%无形》由克里斯·贝鲁布制作，埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德协助编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，天鹅真实乐队和乔治·兰福德提供音乐，格雷厄姆进行事实核查
Hayesha. Carlos Moreno's book, The 15-Minute City, A Solution to Saving Our Time and Our Planet is available now. Special thanks this week to Rebecca Rossman, Sheena Rossiter, and Hannah Aguru. Our executive producer is Cathy Tu. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Our digital director is Kura Kolstad. Our intern is Taylor Shedrick. The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Gabriella Gladney, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lasha Madone, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Nina Potok, Jaka Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We were part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM
海沙。卡洛斯·莫雷诺的书《15分钟城市：拯救我们时间与地球的解决方案》现已出版。本周特别感谢丽贝卡·罗斯曼、希娜·罗斯特和汉娜·阿古鲁。我们的执行制片人是凯茜·图。我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔。我们的数字总监是库拉·科尔斯塔德。我们的实习生是泰勒·谢德里克。团队的其他成员包括杰森·德莱昂、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·李、拉莎·马多内、凯利·普赖姆、乔·罗森伯格、尼娜·波托克、贾卡·梅迪纳·格利森以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM
podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
播客家族的一员，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于美丽。奥克兰市中心，加利福尼亚州。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及99PI过去每一集的链接，网址是99PI.org。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。